[Aplausos]
había una vez un niño que tenía un sueño
y ese sueño era encontrar un dinosaurio
y como buen niño que era
estaba convencido de que lo va a
encontrar
y bueno ustedes ya deben adivinarlo lo
encontró
pero no encontró cualquier dinosaurio
en un dinosaurio único especial y
rarísimo
los padres de este niño son dos geólogos
que en sus expediciones en patagonia a
veces lo llevaban en el extremo sur de
chile y ahí a veces también veía a sus
padres inclinarse en las rocas a hablar
entre ellos leer cosas raras en las
rocas y después empezar a hablar de
mundos desaparecidos de volcanes donde
no hay volcanes de mares profundos donde
ahora hay ríos pero lo que más le
impresionó fue aquella vez en que
golpearon una roca se abrió y salió una
ostra petrificada
aprendió la importancia de los fósiles
aquellos restos de organismos pasados
convertidos en piedra pero lo que más le
interesaba eran los huesos hueso que
encontraba los agarraba lo llevaba donde
los papás y le decía es este el hueso de
un dinosaurio iglesia no es de una vaca
pero insistía volvía a buscar un hueso
lo traía con los ojos allí y éste
tampoco es una vaca pero empezó a
preguntar y se le decía es una vértebra
es un fémur es una costilla y algo
aprendió de huesos y aprendió más aún
tocando los y viendo su textura
este niño se llama diego y soy su padre
cuando tenía siete años lo llevamos con
mi señora también geóloga en un proyecto
al sur del lago general carrera en la
región de aysén en las cordilleras era
un proyecto del fondo nacional de
ciencia y tecnología
auspiciado en ese entonces por el
servicio geológico de chile y
posteriormente por la universidad andrés
bello
llegamos al sitio a caballo este es la
gran carrera y partimos a caballo aquí
cruzamos un río que a veces nos da paso
porque viene muy caudaloso y la zona de
trabajo no la veo bien pero me parece
que aquí
sobre la línea de bosques todo lo que
ven ahí en verde es vegetación lo blanco
es nieve y lo café son cerros pelado
como la zona de nuestro trabajo esa era
la zona de trabajo cuando llegamos allí
arriba diego inmediatamente se bajó el
caballo
corrió hacia nosotros a pedirnos
prestado un martillo de geólogo se lo
pasamos y partió en su búsqueda
solitaria al cabo de un tiempo regresó
con algo en las manos y nos dijo
encontré huesos de dinosaurio quedamos
sorprendidos no se me había pasado por
la mente que eso podía ocurrir ahí
veíamos la roca y no había no veíamos
ningún ningún hueso el tema es que eran
muy pequeñitos si ustedes se fijan ahí
hay un huesito y aquí hay otro
incrustado en la roca
entonces no era fácil de verlos
mi señora por los estudios que había
hecho estaba convencida de que estas
rocas eran del jurásico
un periodo de los tantos en los cuales
se divide la historia de la tierra y
arriba está el jurásico bueno por allá
reg hasta allá
si fuera realmente del jurásico esa roca
muy bien podría ser huesos de
dinosaurios porque era una época en que
vivían los dinosaurios
y quedamos con eso ahí ahora que diego
haya encontrado los huesos era una
probabilidad bastante baja
porque debieron haber ocurrido muchas
coincidencias primero que el animal
cuando murió debió haber sido enterrado
inmediatamente para que los huesos no
fueran descompuestos
luego ese entierro esa tumba del
dinosaurio debe haber existido una serie
de rocas arriba y por millones de años
millones de años no debe haberle pasado
nada a ese ataúd luego cuando la
cordillera se levantó tuvo que haber una
erosión que empezara a eliminar de a
poco las rocas que estaban arriba de los
dinosaurios y dejar justo esa capital
justo esa cápita con los dinosaurios
expuesta en la superficie además deben
estar por sobre la línea de los bosques
se han estado en el bosque no lo
hubiéramos visto y después la otra
coincidencia es que tenía que
encontrarlo alguien que tuviera un
mínimo conocimiento de huesos de huesos
fósiles y alguien que lo anduviera
buscando
todo eso se tuvo que dar para que
encontraran al dinosaurio bueno nosotros
empezamos a buscar encontramos y por
cinco años íbamos
a la zona por unos cinco días cada año y
sacábamos huesos aislados y con mi
señora decidimos completamente que los
que tenían que estudiar lo eran
paleontólogos en argentina porque los
paleontólogos de dinosaurio en argentina
son de nivel mundial además y los
geólogos chilenos y argentinos tenemos
muy buenas relaciones las fronteras
somos ciencias de terreno las fronteras
no existen para nosotros hay muchos
proyectos en conjunto y hemos hecho
muchas amistades
así que contactamos a fernando novas
marcelo y sas y federico año link
nicolás chimentos en el museo argentino
de ciencias naturales buenos aires y
leonardo salgado en la universidad de
río negro y ellos recibían nuestros
huesos aislados
y decían bueno este es un carnívoro este
es un herbívoro este es un tipo de
dinosaurio este es otro tenemos una
fauna de dinosaurio interesante
empezamos a ir juntos a terreno y ahí
cambió la metodología cuando había un
conjunto de huesos como esos que ven ahí
se cortaba
con cierta
una losa
de roca y posteriormente en laboratorio
se empezaba a limpiar a sacar todo lo
que era esta roca de acá y dejar los
huesos libres pelado para el estudio
y así se descubrió esta maravilla
un ejemplar prácticamente completo de
cola a cráneo
de un dinosaurio y en él se empezó a
reconocer todos aquellos huesos que
antes se creía venían de distintos
dinosaurios estaban en este solo ahí
nació el chile saurios diego suárez y
como un dinosaurio único
misterioso un rompecabezas de huesos que
tienen afinidades con distintos tipos de
dinosaurios algo rarísimo muy difícil de
clasificar
existen dos grupos principales de
dinosaurios y el estudio de novas y
colaboradores en que participe
que fue publicado en el 2015 se concluyó
que pertenecía a este grupo dentro de
una línea de carnívoros pero herbívoro
rarísimo pero acá
pero en estos dos grupos el chile
saurios anda como por aquí
otro grupo de paleontólogos de cambridge
en este año proponen una hipótesis alter
alternativa y la ponen acá en estos
libros también en los litigios pero con
alguna conexión con los de aquí no digo
más pero eso es pero la situación no
está zanjada porque nosotros tenemos
nuevas colecciones y seguimos trabajando
en ellos
chiles auroux que medía tres metros el
más grande no estaba solo también había
huesos gigantes de los de tres tipos de
los grandes herbívoros de cuello y cola
larga ahí ven ustedes un hueso grandote
que lo encontramos después de mucho
y también hay cocodrilos que aún no
están siendo estudiados falta que lo
estudiamos troncos fósiles de coníferas
las rocas en las cuales están todos
estos dinosaurios eran antiguos
depósitos de ríos ríos que llegara al
mar
había volcanes como de ese tipo en la
cual había erupciones muy muy explosivas
en que la lava se fragmentaba en miles
de fragmentos y bajaba por los flancos
de los volcanes como nubes ardientes a
velocidades mayores de 200 kilómetros
por hora
y arrasaban con todo
hasta aquí tenemos una película más o
menos más o menos clara de lo que pasaba
pero faltaba un dato fundamental
de los dinosaurios pero precisarla
y para eso nos ayudaba nuevamente las
rocas
acá tenemos rocas verdes y rojas las
verdes eran las elementales que tenían
los fósiles las rojas rocas son rocas
orgánicas que tienen la particularidad
de que se le puede obtener
en millones de años con métodos radios
biométricos
lo hicimos en laboratorios de la
universidad nacional de australia
obtuvimos tres edades coincidentes en
148 millones de años eso es jurásico
superior es decir realmente mi señor es
decir la razón era jurásico iii
estábamos ante un parque jurásico de
verdad en la patagonia en aysén cerca
imagine grande un parque jurásico con
una variedad grande de dinosaurios de
los grandes más de 15 metros toneladas
que pesaban el chile sauro extrañísimo
pero más pequeño
cocodrilos bosques de coníferas volcanes
en erupción a veces un rato ríos que
llegaban un mar terremotos y tal vez de
habría habido tsunami pero no había
seres humanos
no había flores ni pasto no habían
aparecido aún no había cordillera los
andes' no existía tampoco existía el
atlántico en esa época américa del sur
estaba pegada a áfrica y con otros
continentes formadas en mega continente
de gondwana todo este viaje en el tiempo
qué hemos hecho siguiendo la historia
del chile sauro
la hicimos guiados por especialistas de
distintas áreas de distintos países
y todo se inició
cuando un niño siguió sus sueños
ninguna cortapisa sin ninguna frontera
que lo parara
entonces lo que aprendí
es que los sueños sí se pueden hacer
realidad
que conviene seguirlos
finalmente hacen la vida más entretenida
y en una de esas cambian el mundo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]